Hey guys, welcome to my channel. Thank
you guys for watching. Today another
episode. We're working on a 2017
Honda
HRV. So, what we're doing here is we're
adding a key. We're working with the
Altel KM100. If you see that type of
remote, I did generate that remote with
the Xhorse Promax tool. And then that's
a XN remote that we're using here. So
once I generated that remote, I'm able
to go ahead and program this key
specifically to this vehicle. So what
we're doing here, we do have the key on
the on position and we're doing an auto
detect to go ahead and just extract the
data. So it can go ahead and connect to
the the computer so it can retrieve all
the information. If you could see there,
it's giving you some option if it's a
smart key, a blade key. So we go ahead
and choose it's a blade key. Then we're
going to go to the hot functions and
choose that option. And then it's going
to go ahead and communicate with the
computer.
So there it's a fourth keyblade system.
So here all we're doing is adding a key
since we have the original key handy.
So we're going to go ahead and start
with the original key in the ignition.
That's going to give you step-by-step
instructions here.
So, if you see there, it's basically
checking the security system. Since we
have an original key, it's going to
bypass the security system. And so, it
did. Then, it's going to tell you to
turn the ignition off. Then, turn the
ignition on
using the registered key within 17
seconds.
And now it says key programming
succeeded. But basically, if you want to
program the new key, you push yes.
So, what it's going to do is going to
tell you to remove the original key and
then add the new key into the system.
So, if you can see there, the new key
has been programmed.
Then turn the ignition off. Then turn
the ignition on.
Then turn the ignition off.
Then turn the ignition on.
[Music]
Did the immobilizer light uh remove? And
yes, it did. It was not. Usually the
immobilizer will start blinking if it's
not removed. But in this case it was
removed. So we went ahead and hit yes it
was removed.
Then if you can see there red key
numbers
number three. It was from two. Now we
added that key. Now it's number three.
So that's how we went ahead and
programmed the remote. And there you go.
It starts up the vehicle with no
security light on the dash. This was a
successful programming. If you guys have
any questions or concerns, please leave
me a comment on the on below and I'll go
ahead and answer them as soon as I can.
Please like and subscribe to my channel.
I'll go ahead and help you out in
anything you need. I know these new
locksmiths have a lot of questions, so
go ahead and ask away.